talking about the second law you know
one of the things that's fun and
interesting is it turns out probably
some of the things that we're learning
about the second law are actually
relevant to Ai and llms see I think one
of the things that is an emerging
interest here is what we might call llm
science
Tim
you get an llm you train it on billions
of web pages then you discover that has
all kinds of behaviors
and the question is what can you
generically say about those behaviors
it's a little bit like saying you've got
a bunch of you know trillions of gas
molecules in a room and they're all
bouncing around and what can you say in
the aggregate about their behavior it's
sort of a somewhat similar kind of
question but in the case of llms we're
with things like you know how does zero
shot learning how does that work why
does that happen why does anything like
that happen